this is where delegates from nearly 200
countries will be scrambling over the
next two weeks to reach a deal that can
save the planet the meeting in Katowice
at the heart of Poland's coal region
comes three years after the landmark
Paris Accord the envoys gathering at cop
24 aims to produce a rulebook to flesh
out the broad details that were agreed
in Paris limiting the rice and global
temperatures to between 1.5 and 2
degrees Celsius the sense of urgency is
palpable this is a very very important
conference it takes place also in a
scenario where we have a clear signals
about the urgency with which we need to
address the issues of climate change the
effects that are happening are being are
affecting communities around the world
casualties destruction in so many places
in Brussels tens of thousands of people
demonstrated to raise awareness of
climate change and the protesters had a
message for the delegates gathering in
Poland
of opportunity that we need to read
Rossa both
if we saw a plan of action now my girl
grandchildren my cell have a chance
always need to start now just
and time is of the essence to keep
global warming well under two degrees
experts say emissions must drop by up to
70 percent over the next three decades
with global emissions rose in 2017 and
are on track to do the same this year
[Music]
the venue for the UN climate talks in
Katowice it's shrouded in smog more
power plant fueled by coal the polluting
hydrocarbon has been mined here since
the 18th century around 100,000 people
in the region work in the coal industry
[Applause]
is a treasure if there was no cold there
would be no work if the mines closed all
the shops and businesses in the region
would go bankrupt Poland will continue
to generate most of its electricity from
coal until 2050 meaning that the minds
of Katowice will not shut down anytime
soon
coal is what sustains Upper Silesia it's
the primary product of this region and
of course many people here are biased we
know which way the wind is blowing all
over the world and which part we should
be going down each Association achieved
through municipal only 15 percent of
electricity produced in Poland is from
renewable sources activists complained
that the government has neglected to
develop the alternative energy sector
activists scientists citizens mining and
energy sector said we are ready for
change the only group of which is not
interested in change politicians for
Poland's government Katowice is a model
green city it boasts a research center
for renewable energy a shopping mall has
been built on top a closed down coal
mine
even the conference center that hosts
the climate talks stands on the site of
a former mine but the fact remains
Katowice and coal are inextricably
linked and will be for some time to come
Diaby cars for an Edina Banja Luis is at
the cut of its a conference and joins me
from there we have many warnings about
the immediate and urgent need for cuts
in emissions yet as we saw some
governments are simply not doing enough
how important is this climate change
meeting then well this climate change is
the most importance is the 2015 Paris
agreement back then world leaders agreed
to kick global warming under two degrees
Celsius above pre-industrial levels they
decided what they wanted to do but now
they have to decide how they will
actually manage to do that for that
reason the result of this meeting should
be the so-called rulebook which is a set
of guidelines on how countries should
monitor their greenhouse gas emissions
report under climate efforts as well as
climate finance that's a very important
topic because industrialized countries
have pledged to allocate 100 billion
u.s. dollars to help poor countries
covered with climate change effects but
it remains unknown how they will
actually mobilize that money coalface
out will probably also be a hot topic
this year since the conference is taking
place in Poland which is largely relying
still in this dirty fossil fuel and
experts say we are heading towards a
critical point when it comes to co2
emissions give us a sense as to where we
are right now well I think most people
could already experienced the
devastating effects of climate change in
their own skin this year from wildfires
in California to flooding in Japan or
even droughts in Germany but also the
scientific community is warning on the
importance of raising climate ambition
so for instance recently the United
Nations Environment Programme released
the emissions cap report which shows
there is a huge gap between where we are
and where we should be in terms of co2
emissions if we want to reach the Paris
goals we have to reduce our emissions by
a quarter by 2030 if we keep the way we
are doing now we may end up with three
point two degrees above pre-industrial
levels by the end of the center
now Donald Trump is once again
reiterated he's going to pull the u.s.
out of the Paris climate Accord is it
possible to arrest climate change long
term without the world's biggest economy
on board well it's important to remind
first of all that despite Trump
reaffirming his intention of withdrawing
from the Paris agreement this won't
happen legally until 2020 by then things
may have changed greatly on the other
hand countries are increasing the
ambition in view that he's pulling out
from the Paris agreement as well as
local actors and the civil society
so let's civil society won't give up in
the US and at a global level I think
other countries will increase their
ambition so that we are still on track
to reach the Paris college arena by
nurseries thank you very much for that
update from the Katowice climate
conference